look at me in Orange shut up were you
drinking mom do we really have to do
this
everybody is going to be there Mom I
don't care your father and I are not
about to let you drive two hours to go
to a concert and then spend the night
with a bunch of boys especially that 17
year old hormone you're dating it's
totally supervised oh really by whom by
Spencer patine's Uncle who Spencer
patine you know Spencer the guy with the
arm wait what kind of arm what does that
even mean his uncle is Uncle Toby oh
Uncle Toby I'll be sure to include that
in my Amber Alert oh my God can I step
in here I think I can help Haley what
your mom is worried about is you getting
your heart broken when Dylan goes off to
college next year she's not what I mean
he's not going to college he's in a band
okay they're going on tour oh this just
gets better and better oh why are you
always on me about everything okay now
everybody calm down let's start from the
beginning
what's wrong with Spencer's arm
oh didn't appear representing my
classmate when for the past
I read the rest of your speech
congratulations
do you hate me
what you talk about how all the popular
kids are shallow and lame I didn't mean
you you think you have everyone figured
out but everybody has their stuff what
stuff do you have
too many boys chasing after you too many
parties
you really want to know what stuff I
have yeah
I'm flunking out of biology and now I
have to go to summer school
my friends all they can ever talk about
nowadays is going off to college and I
don't even know if I can get into
college
is that enough stuff for you whatever
you know what
fine give your stupid speech be an
outcast but you're only doing it to
yourself because you're smart and pretty
and sort of funny in a way that I don't
really get but other people seem to
enjoy so you can either start fresh next
year or be the freak who flipped off her
class
you really think I'm pretty shut up
what is all this hey hey Mom I'm trying
to write this stupid college essay
question and I really don't even know
okay what's the question tell me what's
the biggest obstacle you've ever had to
overcome did my third grade teacher say
I had like 80d or something oh no honey
she said you couldn't add and she put it
that way because she also knew you
couldn't s p e l l wait slow down oh oh
I was prom so fun Michael and I danced
on light and then we stayed after and
helped clean up which was awesome
because I got to meet next year's Drake
teacher it's not the problem I remember
I have such a bad headache that's the
problem I remember were you drinking mom
do we really have to do this you ask if
I was drinking I say no when we both
know that that's not true
I mean aren't we past this point in our
relationship no young lady we are not
and I wasn't drinking
me neither Mrs d
ude dear God told me he did not spend
the night here Mom do we really have to
do this
Haley hurry up you're gonna be late Alex
what are you doing I need to document
Haley's first day in the Chain Gang it's
not a chain gang it's community service
and leave her alone she feels bad enough
as it is okay I'm torn on one hand I'm
like I have to pick up garbage all day
and on the other hand I'm like look at
me in Orange
oh that's cute send that to me Haley had
a little run in with the law in college
she was arrested for assaulting a police
officer accidentally I fell on him while
evading arrest for underage drinking
that was on purpose they were very
lenient with her she only has to do
community service because I do not have
any priors taking a little too much
pride in that sweetheart
honey yeah that's weird it is yeah
really honey can you help us I don't
think anyone can just let Andy hold you
officer in a gentleman's style and I'll
superimpose Beth's face over yours on
the computer that's insane I know I can
do anything with this if she's not
comfortable you know what guys this
whole thing is really sad and pathetic
no girl wants a guy that tries this hard
if I got this video I'd call the police
some girls actually like guys who are
nice to them some girls like 36 of them
there's 37 of them okay this is Passion
we can use it Andy pick her up
all right let's just get this over with
oh my gosh he's actually picking me up
Dad this is for a minute now lock eyes
and action
honey
long way of saying I miss you
I don't have to climb a mountain or swim
an ocean to be with you
because you're always with me
thoughts
my dreams
my heart
you deserve more than I could possibly
ever give you
but everything I have is yours
I love you
it was beautiful I really felt that one
did you feel that one no I didn't feel
anything I was talking to Andy
thank God you're here peel this orange
for me Mr
assistant job I have been studying your
work and I have to say the looks that
you did for New York Fashion Week I'm
really too busy right now
but I drove all the way down here we had
an appointment yeah I looked at your
blog it's a little too cutesy for me I
need someone with Edge I have Edge you
really don't you are literally the most
wide-eyed person I've ever seen you have
the face of a cartoon lamb thanks for
coming by though
what is that I wanted the peel
hey
it's weird you don't like cutie
considering half your clients at the
Grammys look like they just stepped out
of a My Little Pony fever dream that's
good but not at me never at me Nikki
stop
there are five things wrong with Nikki's
outfit what are they
right there
for uniboob The Watch
boots at come on that built the 97 out
for three years and that's five
now should I do you
hey
I
I feel kind of
bad about before don't we didn't do
anything I know it just felt like
something could have if everybody hadn't
yeah
you know what it is
it's the house it's the house I mean
you're the fireplace the music the crazy
couch bed maybe one could have gotten
swept up anyone anyone yeah
well I should get going yeah yeah
totally I mean it was a fun afternoon
though
I wanted one crazy adventure before I
got married and
got one good
it was fun
I'll see you later
yep
[Music]
[Music]
is Vayner not here yet oh no he is yeah
signed a headshot I didn't ask for and
then went to the bathroom there's his
daughter
I've never met a boyfriend's daughter
before I mean I went out with Stacy's
dad but I've known her since like
kindergarten you're nervous I mean how
could this go wrong she's a teenage girl
that's when you peaked I know I guess I
just really like this gun I want to be
able to show him I can fit into the more
complicated parts of his life hey
princess hey
six people filmed me arguing with that
meter maid and no one caught this
adorable moment
so you must be April oh yeah April tone
I'll grab a chair
it's all right nice work gotta take that
anyways I'm Haley your dad's uh latest
yes flash flood in the Mojave they need
me to cover the water's already ramp
high at the senior center you know a
puppy floats by on a pizza box this
could be National oh snakes our day I'll
just go to Mom and Jeff's no no we were
supposed to get to know each other today
um I can watch you because I'm four oh
tone are you sure yeah
yeah cross day we'll meet you later okay
okay thank you for understanding sweetie
no problem
tragedy strikes dozens dead
tragedy strikes doesn't Ted
you're paying for that
oh my God
I just saw my reflection I told you that
sure was going to drink out my lipstick
timing
the lipstick went up my nose it's really
jammed up there oh okay
stay still Haley I'll hit you from the
other side
what are you doing
just want to let you know the X-ray
shows no broken nose I guess we figured
out we were acting kind of childish
enjoy it while you can right yeah who's
who says we have to race into being
adults why wouldn't you want to enjoy
Carefree life as long as you could at
least until the baby comes oh that's
years away trust me
actually we always run a blood test
before anesthesia you're pregnant
[Music]